I was making a comment on your parents I
was just saying that you go to be what I
was stating a fact that's all this is
the opening scene of the social network
and this is what that dialogue looks
like in a graph you don't have to study
why are you keep saying it once because
you go to beat you the social network
was written by Aaron Sorkin a writer
whose scripts are often described as
rhythmic or musical but those
descriptors are vague and I wanted to
find out exactly why Sorkin's writing
sounds so distinctive I don't understand
which part so I counted every syllable
in each line of dialogue and put it in a
chart I did my best to pick several
other two-person scenes with similar
attributes and compared the graphs of
these scenes to the one from the social
network and what you end up with is
pretty amazing you can actually see the
rhythm of how Sorkin writes compared to
other writers I also compared this
particular social network scene to other
pieces that Sorkin I've written and
found similar patterns across his
writing so what exactly are these
rhythmic elements and why does sort can
incorporate them in his writing well the
first thing that stands out when
comparing this scene to others is that
Sorkin uses longer lines of dialogue in
the opening scene for the social network
Sorkin has nine lines of dialogue that
are over 45 syllables long more than
twice as many as are in the opening of
When Harry Met Sally one of the film
scenes most similar to the social
network the upside of sprinkling these
mini speeches throughout the scene is
that it creates some more variations in
the rhythms of the dialogue by pairing
these longer lines with the quick and
witty banter that Sorkin is known for
fishing be impressed with my education
I'm sorry I don't have a rowboat so
we're even he prevents the exchanges
from getting too repetitive if every
line in the scene was roughly the same
length the exchanges would get dull you
can also see just the sheer amount of
dialogue in this one scene Serkan fits
considerably more lines of dialogue into
this five-minute scene than other writer
scenes of the same length while part of
this is due to the fact that Sorkin
likes to write characters who naturally
speak fast he tailors his scripts to
ensure faster dialogue in several ways
first he writes very few action lines
compared to other writers
in Sorkin also controls the speed of the
dialogue by frequently having characters
interrupt and speak over each other I'm
sorry I mean it I have to be someone you
don't have to study you don't have to
study let's just talk I can't
so why increase the speed of dialogue
obviously it's entertaining to listen to
but there's more to it than that
having faster dialogue allows for more
variation in the tempo of the scene for
a good example take a look at this clip
you don't have to study why are you keep
saying about this because you go to beat
you the blurring exchange of dialogue
between the characters increases the
impact of the subsequent pause making
the moment much more jarring the
syllable chart is great for looking at
the broad patterns of rhythm in Sorkin's
writing but to understand how he
composes his words to give his dialogue
a musical quality I took a closer look
at his writing while it is natural for
words to repeat themselves in dialogue
Sorkin has an extreme amount of
repetition in his scripts take a look at
the opening of the social network
everything that's highlighted is a word
or phrase that's repeated in fact out of
the hundred and forty one sentences in
the scene 22 of them are repeated
essentially verbatim that's 15 percent
of the sentences in the scene when
looking at the scenes from other films
they have nowhere near as much
repetition by listening to these lines
of dialogue you can tell that Sorkin is
intentionally repeating these specific
words and phrases to create a rhythm
that simply sounds good one friends
he's being polite I have no intention to
be friends this repetition is fun to
listen to regardless if you pick up on
it or not as Sorkin aptly puts it what
the word sound like is as important to
me as what the words mean if you can
believe it there's actually one more
literary trick that Sorkin embeds in his
dialogue writing in meter meter is a
poetic structure that was famously used
by Shakespeare in many of his plays and
sonnets there are several types of meter
I won't get into the details here but
one of the most famous versions is
iambic meter which is the repetition of
one unstressed and one stressed syllable
because I am back meter naturally sound
so appealing some say it sounds like a
heartbeat a number of famous lines from
film history are written in it et phone
home
each phone home you had me at hello
in some of Sorkin's own characters in
the West Wing
discuss the merits of writing and meter
he wrote a dissenting opinion and what
I'm almost certain is trochaic
tetrameter so it should come to no
surprise that Sorkin incorporates meter
into his own writing especially for some
of his most memorable lines to give his
writing a little more rhythm in
important moments I mean dollars isn't
cool you know it's cool
using meter is a small way to make a
sentence and naturally sound more
pleasing as Sorkin describes it the
actors will know if they have dropped a
syllable the same way if you're playing
music and there's a time signature at
the beginning of it it says 4/4 time
there can't be 5 beats in a measure
there can't be three beats in a measure
and that's the whole point the key to
why Sorkin's writing is so exciting to
listen to is that it literally sounds
like music almost any song will do but
one song that is a particularly good
comparison to Sorkin's writing is
anything you can do I can do better from
the musical Annie Get Your Gun the
parallels are pretty obvious is the most
diverse the fly club
I have to go Sonny you don't have to
study why are you keep saying it or cuz
you go to beat you anything you can do I
can do better
million dollars isn't cool you know what
school you Sorkin's melodic dialogue is
just plain fun to listen to the rhythm
and the pulse are engrossing at times I
don't understand the technical jargon
that he uses in his scripts but it's
still completely entrancing and this is
what I think makes Sorkin's writing so
special by putting in the extra effort
to layer his dialogue with rhythms and
melodies he ensures that his scenes are
incredibly entertaining to listen to and
I would have to agree with Sorkin when
he says it's not just that dialogue
sounds like music to me it actually is
music
[Music]
you